DOZENS OF OFFICERS FACE
TERMINATION.
IN A LETTER ON FACEBOOK THE
UNION PRESIDENT SAYS SEVERAL
LEGITIMATE EXEMPTION REQUEST
WERE DENIED ADDING QUOTE WILLFUL
ATTACKS ON PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL AND CONTINUED RUSHED
PLANNING AROUND THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC IS PUTTING LIVES AT
RISK AND CAN I ADD THIS WHOLE
NUMBERS ARE IN RETREAT
ESPECIALLY IN MASSACHUSETTS?
THE PRESIDENT OF THE STATE
POLICE ASSOCIATION OF
MASSACHUSETTS SERGEANT MIKE
CHEVRON JOINS US NOW.
HOW BAD ARE THINGS IN
MASSACHUSETTS RIGHT NOW.
HOW MANY MEN AND WOMEN ARE TOLD
TO GO HOME?
>> WE'RE RECEIVING LETTERS
APPROXIMATELY 10 TO 12 DAY.
AND THEY ARE BEING DENIED,
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS.
HOWEVER, THE ODD PART HERE IS
THEY ARE BEING TOLD THAT THEY DO
HAVE MEDICAL CONDITION, AND/OR A
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION THAT SHOULD
BE ALLOWED BUT BECAUSE THIS
ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT ALLOW
FOR OUR TROOPERS TO WEAR A MASK
OR GET REGULAR TESTING, THEY ARE
GOING TO BE SEPARATED FROM
SERVICE.
EITHER THROUGH RETIREMENT,
TERMINATION OR FORCED
RESIGNATIONS.
BRIAN: YOU TELL ME THE FORCE IS
2700 DOWN TO 2,000.
EVERY DAY MORE AND MORE NAMES
ARE BEING RELEASED OF PEOPLE
RELEASED FROM THEIR JOBS.
HOW DOES THE STATED GOING TO
RESPOND TO THIS MESSAGE.
>> THEY WILL BE SEEING DELAYS IN
SERVICE.
THIS MORNING WE ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A STORM AND I JUST
HEARD ON THE RADIO THEY ARE
HOLDING OVER THE MIDNIGHT SHIFT
IN ORDER TO FILL ALL THE CALLS
FOR SERVICE BECAUSE OF DOWNED
TREES, FLOODING AND THE LIKE,
AND THAT'S GOING TO BECOME THE
NORM.
WE WILL BE SEEING TROOPERS HELD
OVER, WORKING LONGER HOURS.
INCREASED CASE LOADS AND THE
POTENTIAL IS THERE FOR, YOU
KNOW, INCREASE IN HOMICIDE
SOLVABILITY RATES ARE GOING TO
GO DOWN.
BRIAN: THOUSANDS FACE THE SAME
THING NOVEMBER 1st IN NEW
YORK.
GOING TO BE JOINING YOU.
SERGEANT, WAS THIS THERE THIS
MUCH CONCERN ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
FIRST RESPONDERS AND ESSENTIAL
WORKERS LIKE YOU AND YOUR MEN
AND WOMEN WHEN THIS PANDEMIC
FIRST HIT AND TRYING TO FIND OUT
WHAT IT IS AND WHERE IT IS FROM
AND SCRAM TO BE GET A VACCINE?
WERE PEOPLE THAT CONCERNED ABOUT
YOUR WELFARE THEN?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT THE
CITIZENRY WAS.
I WOULDN'T SAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT.
THEY ARE NOT AS -- AT THIS POINT
IN TIME, CONCERNED WITH US AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF PUBLIC SAFETY
STATE LEVEL IN MASSACHUSETTS.
BRIAN: DO YOU THINK THEY
UNDERSTOOD WHAT THEY'RE GETTING
INTO?
JUST BECAUSE MOST GOT VACCINATED
THEY THOUGHT OKAY, I WILL FORCE
THE REST.
BUT DO THEY REALIZE THIS FORCE
NEEDS TO BE 100 PERCENT.
BRIAN: I BELIEVE THAT'S IT RIGHT
THERE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THEY TRULY
UNDERSTOOD THAT WE DO HAVE
LEGITIMATE MEDICAL AND RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTIONS AND THEY DIDN'T THINK
THIS OUT.
AND THEY DIDN'T COME TO THE
TABLE AND PROPERLY DISCUSS THIS
WITH US AND NEGOTIATE.
BRIAN: YOU JUST WANT A TESTING
OPTION.
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE HOPING FOR.
>> I JUST WANT OUR TROOPERS FOR
THE ABILITY TO REMAIN EMPLOYED
BY WEARING A MASK AND HAVING A
LEGAL TESTING OPTION, YES.
BRIAN: THE STATE OF WASHINGTON
IS LOOKING AT YOU GUYS AND THE
CHICAGO.
WINS ANOTHER FOUR YEARS HE WILL
PROBABLY DO THAT IN THE STATE OF
NEW JERSEY.
PEOPLE SHOULD LOOK AT
MASSACHUSETTS AND FIND OUT WHICH
IT MIGHT BE STARING AT.
SERGEANT MIKE CHEVRON, THANK YOU
SO MUCH.